Ici, presque tout est écrit
en farsi. Nous sommes au coeur
de la communauté iranienne
de Toronlalala plus grande
au Canada.
Depuis le début du soulèvement
en Iraeseses tensions entre
partisans et opposants au
régime, s'y sont cristallisé.
La police a dénombré plusieurs
incis,s,s, comme à cette
mosquée, qui a été recouverte
de graffitis dénonçant
la république islamique.
Quelques jours plus tard, c'est
un automobiliste qui a foncé
sur des manifestants anti-régime
devant le lieu de culte.
EX MOHAMMAD TAJDOLATI,
journaliste
- On ne peut plus accepter,
si quelqu'un est proche
du gouvernement, il faut payer.
Ilt t t payer pour ça.
C'est pour ça que les gens
décident de montrer leur colère.
- Si les tensions sont si vives,
c'est que le Canada est
idididéré comme un paradis
par les dirigeants du régime
iranien, selon le journaliste.Ee
Justin Trudeau a d'ailleurs
admis la présence de proches
régime de Téhéran sur le
territoire et promis d'en faire
plus pour les empêcher
de s'installer au Canada.
Des promesses accueillies
avec scepticisme par cet avocat
iranien, qui tente d'alert
Ottawa depuis des années.
Sur le site de son organisme,
il appelle maintenant
ses compatriotes à lui envoyer
des informations pour dénoncer
les proches du régime
qui vivent Canada.
Récemment, c'est l'ancien chef
de la police de Téhéran qui a
été aperçu dans une salle
de sport près de Toronto.
"Morteza Talaie est un
commandant de police qui m'a
envoyé en prison, avec tellement
d'autres étudiants. C'est
terrible de voir qu'ils viennent
au Canada en toute liberté.
Ça me rend malade, dit-il."
C'est ce mêasasas-le-bol
qui a poussé cette Torontoise
d'origine iranienne à enquêter
sur les partisans du régime
iranien installés au pays.
Nous avons atétété de protéger
son identité pour éviter les
représailles envers sa famille
en Iran.
"On ne peut pas faire grand-
chose légalement, mais en les
exposant, on peut faire en sorte
que les gens coupent les ponts
avec eux, ou leur commerce",
dit-elle.
Mohammad Tajdolati s'inquiète
des dérives que pourraient
engendrer ces dénonciations en
ligne, mais il dit comprendre
la colère de ses compatriotes.
- Le mur de la peur s'est brisé
pour beaucoup d'iraniens ici.
- Selon lui, les tensions entre
partisans et opposants au régime
ont ououours existé dans la
communauté. Mais depuis le début
du soulèvement en Iran, la peur
a changé de camp.
Ici Andréane Williams,
Radio-Canada, Toronto